bienvenido al regreso y bueno hice un
desastre con esta hoja de balance si es
que hay que borrarla
y vamos a volver a darle entonces bueno
quitamos un montón de activos para pagar
deudas y lo que nos quedó de activos
aquí en nuestra hoja de balance es un
poco de efectivo un billón de pesos en
efectivo
un billón de pesos en efectivo y bueno o
sea no puedes simplemente usar este
efectivo para pagar tus deudas porque
necesitas este efectivo para hacer tus
operaciones de todos los días para hacer
las transacciones con tus clientes y
pagar la renta y mandatos ejecutivos en
aviones y bueno este dinero se llama
capital de trabajo
pero bueno regresando al tema de este
vídeo entonces tenemos un millón de
pesos en efectivo y al menos la
administración de este banco creo que
también tenemos 4 billones en sede o
residenciales ok
este es el activo en el que se enfoca el
rescate financiero del gobierno que fue
algo histórico por sus proporciones pero
hablaré más de eso después y luego del
lado de los pasivos
y pasivos
teníamos teníamos el préstamo se lo voy
a pintar en rojo porque es algo malo
bueno en realidad no es malo pero pues
es algo que debemos
entonces y decíamos que el préstamo se
era de 3 billones de pesos entonces cuál
es el capital capital a ver
entonces el total de los activos son 5
billones de pesos
que hay 5 billones
de total de activos y tenemos 3 billones
de pasivos
entonces si crees en lo que la
administración puso en el libro
si quieres simplemente liquidar todo y
obtener tus 5 billones de pesos y pagar
la deuda nos quedan dos billones de
pesos
y bueno habíamos dicho que habían 500
mil millones de acciones
500 mil millones de acciones no medio
billón de acciones
y cada una de esas acciones tiene una
500 mil millonésima parte de ese capital
entonces el valor libro de cada una de
esas acciones es el valor libro del
capital dividida entre quinientos mil
millones o sea dos billones entre
quinientos mil millones que son cuatro
pesos recuerdas que hace mucho eran seis
pesos pero tuvimos que vender estas
hipotecas comerciales que creíamos que
valían diez billones y las tuvimos que
vender a nueve billones que perdimos un
billón de nuestro valor libro y ese
billón menos repercutió como dos pesos
menos en el valor libro de cada acción
pero bueno el valor de mercado o sea
bueno el valor de mercado de cada acción
o sea el precio de la acción digamos que
está un peso por todo esto el asunto
bernstein de lehman brothers torno está
muy asustado y además tienen este activo
que no es muy confiable así es que
debemos de tener mucho cuidado eso es lo
que todo el mundo dice entonces si el
valor de mercado es de un peso que es lo
que están diciendo acerca de los activos
y del capital
bueno calculamos la capitalización de
mercado eso es el precio del mercado por
la cantidad acciones y es equivalente al
valor de mercado el capital o sea a lo
que el mercado cree que vale este
capital o sea un peso por 500 mil
millones o sea 500 mil millones que es
medio billón entonces el mercado está
diciendo no tú no tienes 2 billones de
capital tú sólo tienes medio billón y
eso es porque creen que esto vale un
millón y medio menos pero bueno vamos a
dejar esto a un lado ahora si estamos
llegando al meollo del asunto se acabó
el plazo de los primeros dos préstamos y
nadie quería sustituirlos
entonces la compañía tuvo que liquidar a
algunos de sus activos para pagarlos y
ahora empieza el final del juego tenemos
este préstamo se y se acabó su plazo
entonces dicen que las cosas están muy
turbias y que tus activos se parecen
mucho a los de lehman brothers y bear
stearns y no están dispuestos de renovar
su préstamo vas a los mercados de
crédito tratas de emitir bonos
intentas cualquier cosa nadie está
dispuesto a darte un préstamo porque
todos están muy asustados entonces qué
haces pues tienes que pagar sus tres
billones de pesos simplemente lo tienes
que hacer porque nadie está dispuesto a
darte 3 billones y bueno de este
efectivo no lo puedes usar todo si
quisieras operar con lo indispensable
tal vez podrías poner medio billón del
efectivo pero eso no va a resolver tu
situación porque necesitas otros 2
billones y medio más
entonces wow estás en una situación
donde tienes que vender esos vídeos
vamos a ver si todos tus modelos estaban
remotamente correctos si éstos realmente
valen 4 billones entonces tratas de
vender tu sede o si estás dispuesto a
aceptar casi lo que sea por ellos porque
tienes que venderlos y número uno no hay
un mercado para ellos porque un montón
de personas quieren venderlos pero la
verdad es que no hay casi nadie que
quiera comprarlos pero tú tienes que
venderlos entonces vas con todos los
fondos de cobertura y fondos de capital
privado que hay y les dices quién quiere
comprar mis dedos y alguna firma de
capital privado dice ok yo creo que esas
cosas tienen un efecto tóxico pero
probablemente valen algo y soy muy
optimista con respecto al mercado de
bienes raíces y tal vez dentro de diez
años se recupere entonces estoy
dispuesto a darte un billón por eso sé
de dos esencialmente que es el precio de
mercado de algo es el mejor precio que
alguien está dispuesto a darte por algo
y el precio del mercado de esto como ya
fuiste al mercado y con todos los que
pudiste
y lo que más te ofrecen es un billón ese
es el precio de mercado estos vídeos y
qué puedes hacer si los vendes por un
millón de pesos mejorará tu situación si
lo vendes por un millón de pesos más el
billón de efectivo tienes 2 billones en
total y con eso no alcanzas a pagar el
préstamo sigue siendo te la bancarrota y
además es un precio de remate ese no es
el verdadero precio y la administración
del banco es muy terca y dice si los
vendo me voy a la bancarrota y además
ese es un precio de remate ese no es el
precio verdadero así de la nada por
primera vez en su carrera porque cuando
ganaba 30 millones ellos creían
ciegamente en el mercado pero ahora está
en la negación total del mercado
ellos dicen la única razón por la que
estoy teniendo un billón de pesos es
porque todo el mundo tiene miedo y estas
cosas si alguien las guardará por 30
años con se pagarán todas las hipotecas
obtendrían más o menos 4 billones de
pesos en él
el peor de los casos obtendrían 3
billones y medio entonces pues no voy a
hacer eso pero en verdad no tienen
opción entonces le dices a alguien
puedes darme una especie de préstamo
sólo prestan el dinero a corto plazo
para poder pagar esto y estoy dispuesta
a dar estos cds como garantía una
garantía en un préstamo significa que si
yo no te pago el préstamo te puedes
quedar con el activo y eso es lo que el
gobierno estaba haciendo originalmente
el gobierno solo daba préstamos si
ponías como garantía algo muy bueno como
bonos de tesorería y hacen un descuento
sobre la garantía si le das a la reserva
federal un peso en bonos de tesorería
ellos te prestan como 80 centavos pero
con toda la crisis de crédito el
gobierno se ha puesto cada vez más
flexible con respecto a que está
dispuesto a aceptar como garantía no
conozco cuáles son los activos más
tóxicos que está dispuesto a aceptar
como garantía pero se han puesto
realmente muy flexibles en ese aspecto
entonces tal vez puedas obtener un
préstamo de esos
pero dejemos esta cosa de un a un lado
en esta situación tenemos un banco que
está siendo forzado a caer en la
bancarrota aunque el banco cree que
tiene capital positivo entonces podría
obtener un préstamo del gobierno o de
alguien más si están dispuestos a
aceptar este activo tóxico como garantía
suponemos que no obtienen el préstamo la
otra opción es recapitalizar puedes
conseguir que alguien invierta en tu
compañía puedes vender el capital y
obtener más efectivo para pagar la deuda
si puedes convencer a alguien que tu
compañía va a valer mucho más en el
futuro que esta es sólo una situación
estresante entonces vas con algún fondo
soberano y eso es una forma de llamarle
a un gobierno extranjero que ha reunido
dólares porque ha vendido petróleo o
artesanía barata y le dices mira
nosotros somos el mejor banco sobre la
tierra somos lo máximo tenemos esta
marca grandiosa en la industria bancaria
no te gustaría tener un pedazo de esta
grandiosa cosa que representa el
capitalismo y ellos dicen claro estamos
interesados en invertir
el precio de mercado es de un peso y
creo que está un poco exagerado entonces
estamos dispuestos a pagarte 150 por
acción y compraremos no sé compraremos
bueno cuánto necesitas compraremos 2
millones de acciones a 150 por acción y
qué pasa
digamos que el fondo soberano en serio
va a comprar 2 billones de acciones
a unos 50 pesos por acción
entonces cómo se ve la hoja de balance
ahora 2 billones a 1.5 por acción eso
nos da 3 billones de pesos entonces
tenemos 3 billones más de efectivos y
esto se convierte en 4 billones pero no
lo obtuviste gratis entonces qué está
pasando aumentaron nuestros pasivos no
no aumentaron no nos dieron un préstamo
invirtieron en nosotros compraron
acciones de la compañía 2 billones de
acciones y entonces en lugar de tener
medio billón de acciones eso es justo lo
que teníamos
a la compañía creó de la nada 2 billones
de acciones y ahora la compañía tiene
2.5 billones de acciones
2.5 millones de acciones y algo
interesante cuál es el nuevo valor libro
de la compañía entonces cuál es el total
de nuestros activos 8 billones de
activos y nuestros pasivos siguen
valiendo 3 billones entonces nuestro
capital que son 8 billones menos 3
billones son 5 billones después de la
inversión 8 billones menos 3 billones 5
billones
y bueno veamos cuánto vale cada acción
son 5 entre 2.5 billones o sea 2 pesos
por acción
que hay dos pesos por acción
el nuevo valor libro de las acciones de
cada acción es de dos pesos que está en
medio entre lo que teníamos antes del
valor libro y el precio que pagó el
fondo soberano
era un nuevo cincuenta por acción pero
bueno ya se me acabó el tiempo entonces
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo